only losers should fear recessions if
you are a winner then all that happens
is you just get to eat everyone else's
lunch like that's all it is everyone
else who shouldn't have been in business
now will not be in business and then
whatever little crumbs and whatnot just
filters up to the guys who provide value
so it's still business fundamentals it's
just you get away with less the rules of
the game don't change you just provide
more value at a at a really reasonable
price you do all the things about being
better you contact your leads you follow
up you make sure you do an email
marketing I mean like you're doing all
the things you should be doing it works
in any economy